[Music]
so you got married before yeah
tell us all about it
when you got married
too young
how long were you 24
before you got married four years
oh good four years from childhood
sweethearts from malaysia she's germa we
met in america all at this at the
college yeah yeah and then she went to
london and you said i'm going to no we
both wanted to stay here but visas are
hard to get work visas here is a lottery
system we're both going to get it so
we're like hey i want to speak english
and do comedy and london isn't better
she works in advertising so london's
advertising scene is better as well so
it's a no-brainer for us makes our life
so easy
how'd you guys break up over there then
yeah how
just you know i got too busy with my
career it was very selfish in the sense
that i was just pursuing this thing just
whole tunnel vision
you know so and i still am but i'm
single now so that's okay you know i got
a dream i'm criticizing rice yes
she never believed me in my rice passion
she never believed it right guess what
people love fries
people
you should come out with a rice cooker
uncle roger
uncle roger rice cooker yeah it's hard
though i need to make sure it's good you
should call that i'll call it zoji roger
zoji roger fire and have your own little
song
[Music]
rice is done
dr rice cooker come out with the
microwavable bag of rice oh yeah those
are good
those are good those are [ __ ] good
there's another idea from another guy
right that white guy would say
microwave minute rice who actually loves
it is my trash ass filipino
father-in-law
not the minute rice ones different it's
different no we that's exactly what
you're talking about that's what i'm
talking about
i thought it felt like a hamburger
you're trying to bridge the gap the
minute rice tastes like plastic though
it's terrible yeah it's awful it's
lifeless and soggy
when you when you
broke up with your wife did you ask for
the diamondback
no
relax jesus
don't get mad at me
it's like it's up to her if she wants to
give it back right usually that's fair
what are you going to do do women ever
give it back what are you going to do
with this sometimes they do can you pawn
it like what are you going to do though
i think you got to really [ __ ] up for
the middle like once again it wasn't too
expensive
do you know who de beers is yeah that is
the global diamond mining firm oh
they have now launched a proprietary
blockchain powered platform to manage
all of their diamond production and
distribution what a blockchain platform
so you know that they're not conflict
diamonds uh well yeah exactly so you can
track them from from their point of
origin you can see exactly where it is
on the blockchain you can if you're a
woman isn't it more romantic to get like
a blood diamond
than a fair trade diamond i think some
people would say yeah they want someone
to die i also think some people will say
no
wait who what people who said no i'm
just saying something i'm just trying to
speak for them you don't believe in
romance fool yeah dude because women
want people to die for [ __ ] yeah kinda
it means more anthony we just want you
to agree with everything that we say
okay okay i agree i agree
they already have incorporated don't
give up your morals they've already
incorporated the system into it into
their global operations and they
estimate that 25 of their diamond
production by value is registered on
tracer which is how they're gonna um the
platform that you're using for black you
say twenty-five percent twenty-five
percent of the diamonds seventy-five
percent blood
i think it's just a pr stunt isn't it i
mean the whole uh crypto thing is about
decentralization but it's the beers so
it's it can't be any more centralized
than that you're very right about that
well they're doing this not because of
decentralization they're doing this to
use blockchain as a distributed ledger
to track their supply chain so like from
point of origin to where it goes to the
store they know exactly where it came
from and it can't be [ __ ] with that's
the they're not really they don't care
about the decentralization movement but
i know you're talking
a regular database can store that right
yeah well but it can be the ideas that
it can be [ __ ] with though so like you
could [ __ ] with a database like you know
versus like validated by the blockchain
right yeah
if it's public if it's distributed and
open then everyone can see what happened
that's the idea behind it
so
yeah so they're gonna use this to track
all i mean there's a bunch of companies
that are also following it's like a
carfax for a diamond right oh oh
sort of you know i could see a barcode
inside of the diamond sometimes yeah you
look inside and there's a you go oh my
god and then you can scan it go oh this
one's a conflict diamond yes yeah that's
usually what it is yeah it's hard to
find though have you ever tried to look
at like the actual diamond and look for
the actual like with your naked eye no
with the actual [ __ ] jeweler loop i
guess he's [ __ ] he looks like
man there are those [ __ ] serial
numbers stupid
tell the difference between diamonds and
all the clarity vvsv dude it's so hard
to look around a little black dots in
nicky's diamond i'm like [ __ ] it i give
up what do you put a jeweler's suit on
you'll see that poor african kid just
mining and sweating
yes i want this one
you see a reflection of his soul yeah
you see him crying
i just want my dad i said yeah i'll take
this one
put him on blockchain yes
wait so if i don't want to get too
technical but if things are on the
blockchain that's immutable yeah people
depending on the blockchain right
because you could just get a blockchain
and then you could 51 attack it and you
so you could actually control blockchain
that way yeah okay how are they using
blockchain as a way to like register at
what point is being like distributed in
the logistics because like in amazon
right like let's say um you have a
package then they'll scan it and then
like every single point of scan you know
like where it is and then shipping it's
like oh it's almost at your door because
it's in the [ __ ] van now or whatever
right
so how are they using do you know how
they do that in blockchain uh i think
that they're they're using qr codes qr
codes so like every point like let's say
it's been mined in this you know fair
trade mine and then a diamond scan there
and then it like goes to like germany or
whatever it might be more so not from
the mine but once it's like quote
unquote turned into a diamond it in
essence is like a physical nft so to
speak and then from there it's like
registered on the blockchain and then
whatever happens in the commerce side of
it is like continue to be tracked
yeah none of us know what we're talking
about at this point right we're just
making it up we're just making it up so
listeners don't don't think
when when diane becomes a diamond it has
to get into the hand of either a chinese
or a jewish man and they have to they
have to they have to shave the stone
into a diamond and then it becomes a
diamond but before that they're like
dirty ass little rocks can't they just
be lying every step of the way on the
blockchain they can and they are i don't
know
well that's the thing about it too
because it's a it is a private company
so you could definitely argue that we
don't know how they're going to be doing
it so yeah
yeah they could just have a regular
database like you know postgres or
something if you use if you're a
programmer and then yeah you can just
wait for it all you want yeah yeah and
you just say it's a good pr move isn't
it yeah for them it's probably more of a
pr or a marketing move for people that
aren't going to ask too many questions
like oh it's on the track little
blockchain location if they can start
tracking like
documents paperwork everything through
blockchain 2 i want to see this in
government because i think there's so
much [ __ ] spending
that like if they can have a uh
like for example like let's say they're
gonna build a bridge right and then
everything is transparent and we know
where the money's going we see the price
points we on the ledger you can see
where it's being spent then the whole
public can view where the city treasury
is being spent on because there's so
much [ __ ] corruption that's always
happening where they're like yeah we're
going to build the [ __ ] train
um where's the railway uh we ran out of
money doesn't that already exist most
cities have that publicly no just nobody
reads it the crazy thing is it you can
find it but you just can't do anything
about it right like it's like it
literally is like oh what are you gonna
do though
well i always like to say your your um
economy is being uh duplicated on the
blockchain
all of it so
um you you would just basically see the
city funds and then it goes into a
monero address and then
[Laughter]
uh-oh
so a little privacy token joke there
so that means this corruption you just
can't stop no matter what no matter what
technology is around but if you see it
then at least more people but we can't
see it still we can already see it you
technically have to get an audit like
it's not all public records because
there's some spending we're just like
they're like they're like hey what
happened to all the [ __ ] money we're
like we're getting to it we're getting
to and they never get to it oh dude look
at ukraine i mean we're dumping billions
over there but then they say they don't
exactly know everything that's going on
with it and it's like the pentagon dark
money budget yeah that's why russia
needs to bomb it more to uncover this
just to see like what's under there yeah
that's an interesting take a mystery
it's a mystery
[Laughter]
it's just an expedition that's all it is
auditing ukraine we've moved on ukraine
now though it's not a trendy topic if
they're not putting the ukraine signs on
their twitter accounts i think you're
safe to joke about it everybody wants to
hear about johnny depp and amber that's
the that's nobody gives a [ __ ] about
your prank speaking of giving a [ __ ]
amber heard gave a [ __ ] oh dude if you
ever get divorced make it big
they're getting 10 million views a day
even like the hot lawyer in the glasses
she's getting famous now dude nick just
showed me a video of amber heard getting
up and she sees johnny depp and she's
like
please don't hit me i mean she's been in
the same courtroom as the cat for like
what [ __ ] how many weeks now
horrified but standing up changes the
whole game doesn't it because we're like
this close like it's still [ __ ]
attacking from here right now
that's the best acting i've seen from
her
you know i know that's what everybody's
saying
that's what he said him and his lawyer
actually put out that statement she said
uh that ever heard gave the performance
of her career did they say that they're
so good at it they're so good at trash
talk dude
so funny can you imagine being amber
heard's new pr team that just got hired
i think she should hire us honestly we
could [ __ ] do a way better job i
think i could change her i think if she
was with me i think i could change i
could save her can we do it together
then no me and steve are going to do
that
sorry sorry you have a kid you know what
i mean me and steve can still do it nice
marriage goals man you know because my
career will probably take a downturn in
a few years time that's my next stream
it's staying relevant you know
twitch twitch my divorce
get some brand new before i take the
stand this video this court case is
sponsored by expressvpn
twitch plays your divorce that could be
interesting they make all the decisions
i'll send you some subs dude yeah yeah
let's do it i mean let me find the right
woman for a little bit of crazy in her
eyes i mean in five years time we're
going to be in court together i see it
that's great if your viewers can vote on
who gets what yeah yeah yeah that's good
did your viewers decide if they're old
enough for kisses yeah
that's true
you want them to have that
no context
every video all the time
[Music]
you